τά της αστυνομίας καιος ακούγονται ο τελευταίο διάστημα εμείς ευχαριστούμε για την πρόσκεση γνωρίζω οπιή
πέραςναπο αυτόν τ πόκας και είναι μεγάλη είμαστημή ος εκπροσώπη της συντεχνίας να είμαστε εδώ
ξεκινούμε κυριλοιζίδη θέθελα γανανα σχολειο μια ρώτηση για να το σχολιάζεμαμε συγχορείται για το ότι
πολύ λένε ότι μετά που υπόθεση ας πήγε πίσω μπήκε στο συρτάρι για την ανάρμοστη
στην περιφορά ότι ο νίκος λογιζείτες κάπου πικε λίγο πιο δεξια λίγο δεν σχολειάζει τόσο
πόλι τόσο έντονα τά τις γίνεται στην αστυνομία ούτε δεξια ότε αριστερα απλά να ξεκαθαρίσω
ότι αρχγός αστυνομίας δεν ανέστιλέ αυτός έγραψε ότι ανέστειλε ο κανονισμός λέει οι συνεχίζεις τη
διαδικασία ι τηνα κιρώνεις επέλεξε να καιρώσει τη διαδικασία που ήταν θύμωση συνδικαλισμού και αυτή
ήταν η πρώτη μας διαφωνία με τον με τον νέο αρχιγο αστυνομς αλλά όταν έχεις
γέφυρε σ επικοινωνίας και μπορίς να ανταλλάζεις απόψεις και ήσηγήσεις οι συγκρούσεις είναι αναπόφευτες ο
νικός ολοιζήτηση ς ότητα δεν αλλαξαρότα είναι εκεί η ασπίδα των αστυνομικώ όμως ταν γιατέσσερα
χρόνια δεν ευρίσκαμε μάλλο δεν έβρισκαν άλλη την πόρτα να μας ανοίξουν επειδή εμείς πάμπολλες
φορές ετιθήγαμε για άλλου ίδους κίνητρα και συμφέροντα ι αυτή της στιγμή έχουμε διαύλουση επικοινωνίας
και με το υπουργείο δικαιοσύνης και με τη νιγεσία της αστυνομίας άρα διαφωνούμε σε πολλά
όμως αντιλαβανεστε και σεις κυριών ότι μα διφωνίς μεκάποιώ κα επικοινωνάς διαφορετικών που να διαφωνείς
και να μην επικοινον ασκαθόλονα μιλούμε στον ενικό νομιζόκαιναι απλά ήθελα να θρωίσω και νικό
θεωρίσε ότι έχεις περάσει εωρίς τι είχες περάσει τα όρια για αυτό καιο προηγούμενος αρχηγός